what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back on our regularly scheduled
programming which means kang only myself
left to conquer part uh three is this
part three i can't remember but whatever
the next part is
[Laughter]
that's the part we're doing here now i
was reading over the comments of the
previous videos after i got back and i
noticed that some of you guys were a
little confused in terms of how the
whole king the conqueror thing works and
all that kind of stuff okay so as you
guys know when it comes to marvel comics
the main marvel universe is earth 616
right that's well established you guys
have all pretty much known that for
quite some time what you have is you do
have a nathaniel richards from earth616
but that is the nathaniel richards known
as the father of reed richards so if you
ever read jonathan hickman's fantastic
four run that's nathaniel right now he
does have time traveling escapades and
so on and so forth and he was part of
kang war different things along those
lines but when you think of king the
conqueror right prime king if you want
to call him that the main kane the
conqueror who goes back in time and
fights the avengers and all that kind of
stuff he comes from a reality called
earth 63 11. this story as it's being
told is basically the origin of king the
difference here is that unlike what a
lot of the stuff that you've read before
it's designed to basically rework his
origins slightly as well as massively
rework characters like ravana renslayer
and the reason for that is because
coming out of the loki tv show ravana
renslayer is a very popular character or
at least pretty popular way more than
she ever was in the comics
and so there was a lot of confusion with
her character in the comics if loki had
literally ended and said for more about
ravana renaissance go read marvel comics
as she exists right now it would confuse
the piss out of people they would have
no idea where to start or which version
of her it is or anything like that it
was it was just it was a massively
complicated thing right she was just
kind of thrown in there with a time
traveling escapades of kang and there
was no real explanation given insofar as
how it all ties together this story
corrects that the other part of that is
that where this story focused on
answering the question this idea that
when kane the conqueror was a teenager
some future version of himself just
showed up and said i'm going to turn you
into me that we're in and focused on
younger king trying not to become his
older self this video right here is
where everything begins to shift so in
the last video that we covered we had
basically talked about how there was a
it was really younger king ending up in
ancient egypt and coming across rama tut
who as you guys know was came to conquer
going back to ancient egypt and then
basically trying to rule there and then
conquer the earth from that point going
forward ultimately though there was a
great big war taking place between uh
kane the conqueror and apocalypse and so
as a result of that what you ended up
having was younger king who basically
allied himself with what appeared to be
ravana rinslayer in ancient egypt and
then in turn helping uh helping
apocalypse fend off and really defeat
the forces of rahmatut of course with
king basically fleeing back to his
present after being defeated by the
fantastic four who would time travel to
that time period again we had covered
more of that in the video so if that's a
little confusing to you i invite you to
go back and check out that video the
thing about it is that after that whole
conflict has ended right that adult king
fled back to his own time and all you're
left with is younger kang here in that
whole series of events that whole
calamity ravana rinslayer had
effectively died and so as a result of
that because ravana renslayer had
basically appeared intermittently
throughout the time stream and really
defied anything regarding like the laws
of aging or anything like that and no
explanation has been given yet which we
will we'll get an explanation on that um
basically you have young kang who's in
love with ravana rinslayer he has a
vendetta against his older self and then
he also wants to find a way to save
ravana so what he ends up doing is
making a deal with apocalypse now as you
guys know apocalypse as a villain this
guy's nothing if not just beholden to
evolution right the guy believes in
social darwinism only the strongest
deserve to survive it's one of the
reasons why apocalypse is a little
hypocritical in some ways on one hand
he'll make these grandiose speeches
about how evolution will have its due
and only those who who are able to deal
with you know strength and and show how
capable they are are the ones who
deserve to live all the while he
basically used the techno-organic virus
as it was given to him by cable albeit
inadvertently to interface with
celestial technology and grant himself
all these powers so if he was really
living up to his own belief system he
never would have done that he would have
just used whatever powers had been
naturally given to him to find some way
to be a conqueror so basically it's a
long way for me to say that when it
comes to his life philosophy apocalypse
is foolish so the thing about this is
that what he does is he tells nathanael
like i will give you the ability to
travel forward in time right to travel
to you know your future or whatever time
period you need to go to but you will
not do it using some kind of time
machine or anything like that you will
do it as at the whims and wants of time
herself and so instead of him just being
given the ability to travel into the
future by way of some sort of machine or
something like that he's actually
encased in a sarcophagus and left there
for like thousands of years where he
just kind of goes forward right
literally just sitting there in this
case now the thing about it is that that
kang doesn't really say that this is any
kind of a torture i mean psychologically
it is to a degree but in order to keep
himself from going insane he steals
himself right he says time is a thing to
be conquered that was the edge of king's
knife not tactics nor technology nor
superpowers nor brutality time travel
but even without a machine we all travel
through time slowly and ever forward so
with my flesh protected from age by
apocalypse's arcane technology but my
mind restlessly aware i did that one
thing that king would find abort i took
the long way around and all the while i
sharpened my mind and stealed my focus i
had many coming victories to contemplate
but i was drawn particularly to the
failures the ones i had been trained to
prevent i contemplated ravana the
mystery of her name echoing on my elder
self's lips and of meeting my own ravana
in the distant past i shed my boyhood to
make myself her murderers undoing and
finally in the shadow of 26
964
years of preparation meditation and
patience i arrived and so he basically
shows up here in what's essentially the
modern era right the modern day and when
i say the modern day i mean like the
avengers in the 1960s really is is
really what i'm referring to here
but when he arrives here this
sarcophagus of course is discovered and
of course he ends up breaking out and so
on and so forth but as he's here of
course he overhears a news blip on the
radio from j jonah jameson where
basically there's some kind of uh ufo
right a hovercraft out there that's just
like wreaking havoc and the avengers are
fighting it and so on and so forth and
where they don't quite know what to make
of it and in fact jamison asked a
question like is it invaders from outer
space kang is like no that's my future
self who's arrived here with the
intention of attacking the avengers team
now what's really really interesting
about this and this is what's really
really cool is that you have younger
kang who shows up to this vessel now in
his mind he doesn't spend a whole lot of
time with the avengers they're really
more of an afterthought here and that's
one of the things that's so cool about
this story is whenever we traditionally
read comic books the avengers or
somebody like that they're always in
some capacity the main focus right like
here's a spider-man story where peter
parker's doing his thing and something
happens and some villain shows up and
you know whatever he's really really
strong peter can't do it on his own so
here come the avengers and now it's a
team-up book you don't really see
instances where it's just like and there
are the avengers over there doing
something let's go back to what it is
that we're doing here like you never
really see that all the time right and
it's really i really enjoy it's one of
the things that i love about books like
this is it's basically kang like younger
king who's like i gotta fight my older
self and it's cool to see the avengers
because i remember seeing them when i
was a little kid way you know in the
far-flung future you know when he's from
the 31st century but he's like i
remember seeing them as a little kid
studying about them and like the museum
and the libraries and different things
like that so it's kind of wild to
actually see them here and they kind of
look like i always imagined them in my
memory that they were much bigger than
they are you know they're just people
here who do some stuff so there is a bit
of nostalgia here but it's one of those
things where he doesn't quite have time
to sit back and marvel at the avengers
fighting against you know the forces of
kane to conquer instead king like
younger kang ends up going into the
vessel now it's one of these things and
this is a really really important aspect
of this he says so as the avengers
fought kang with shield and hammer i
approached not as alexander but as
odysseus i made king's timeship know me
as a friend for none could access its
arsenal but king perhaps as i recall it
now that moment was the first time i was
truly him and the reason why he says
that and the reason why this is so
significant is because over the course
of this story younger kang has been
doing everything he can to prevent
himself from becoming older king the
conqueror from like becoming that
villain it's a cool thing here because
in the midst of this battle of course
the avengers kind of get the upper hand
king's ship is is on the verge of
getting ready to take off and younger
kang ends up confronting older kings so
like the videos that we've done in the
past we'll refer to younger king as
nathaniel and older kang is just king
right we'll just call him that so the
thing about this is that kang does not
recognize nathaniel richards and the
reason why he doesn't recognize him is
because kang has not met him yet now i
know it sounds confusing as hell
this is why i say kang stories man you
have to really approach these carefully
like especially if i'm making a video
about this i have to approach it very
very carefully because i could just blow
through it the way that we normally do
with stories it would confuse the piss
out of you so here is a super simple
explanation to why it is that kang does
not know nathaniel so in a previous
video we talked about how kang despite
only being probably in his 30s or so has
traveled back and forth through time a
ton of times and as a result of that you
could argue he's cumulatively lived a
thousand lifetimes and so it's very very
easy to just forget things now what's
important about this is that king the
conqueror at this point in his history
has not traveled back to find his
younger self and basically train his
younger self and teach him everything he
needs to know to prevent him from losing
this is the point in the story when cain
the conqueror is facing off against the
avengers and losing so he hasn't come to
this realization what if i just go back
and grab my younger self and basically
correct all my mistakes in that younger
self so when my younger self becomes me
they won't have all the flaws that i
have now they'll be a better version of
me so they never make the same mistakes
and they ultimately come out on top
right that's why kang does not remember
nathaniel because he hasn't met him yet
because he hasn't come up with that idea
to grab nathanael and teach him
everything he needs to know to ensure
that kang does not lose in these various
fights that he engages in now the thing
about this is remember nathan doesn't
want to become kang so even though he
accesses the ship by pretending to be
kang and so on and so forth he still
stands against him right and one of the
things to keep in mind is he still
harbors a lot of love for ravana
rinslayer and he's still very very mad
about the fact that she died in ancient
egypt because of the actions of kang
when he was pretending or operating
under the moniker of rama tut and so
what he says is that his intention is to
eradicate king right to kill kang here
and now on this ship and by doing so it
would remove him from the time stream in
its entirety at that point he would go
back into the past in ancient egypt and
he would save the life of ravana red
slayer because if he were to go back in
the past and save the life of ravana
king would always end up back there
because it's just his history he would
always become rama tut he would always
exist in ancient egypt and that
situation with how ravana died would
always repeat itself but if he can kill
kang and by doing so purge him from the
time stream in its entirety then
ultimately he can go back to ancient
egypt he can save the life of ravana
live a live life with her and never have
to worry about kang showing up there to
wreak havoc in any capacity because he's
dead right like there's no king to
travel back and forth in time anymore
and so the response of kang is that's
insane like do you have any idea what
you would do if you did that right like
i'm so ingrained in the time stream you
would quite literally break time itself
but if i didn't exist and you killed me
it would destroy time there has to
always be a king there needs to always
be a cane to conquer traveling back and
forth through time engaging in these
different things because this is how
it's supposed to work it's kind of
ambiguous and it's very meta-textual in
terms of how it's explained but really
it points to the greater argument here
that in marvel comics there does always
have to be a kang but king always comes
into existence it always ends up that
way i mean i guess maybe there's a
universe out there where there is no
king the conqueror but that universe has
never been seen right king always exists
in every universe across the multiverse
seemingly every single time now what's
crazy is that in the midst of this
argument between the two suddenly
they're met by the arrival of victor von
doom of doctor doom son now here's a
cool thing right dr doom would normally
never intervene here and he certainly
probably wouldn't take the risk of
showing up and confronting cain the
conqueror in his own ship where he's at
is most powerful but the opportunity is
too good of a chance to pass up that
doctor doom watching the entire conflict
between kang and the avengers and even
being able to see what's going on here
using sorcery and mysticism and whatnot
came to the realization there's two
kangs here there is king from the future
and king came from the past right his
younger self if he can eradicate both
then ultimately it would save doom a lot
of hassle and grief and kang like
standing in his way regarding domination
because one of the things to know is
that it's kind of an unofficial
competition between doom and king in the
sense that like doctor doom wants to
conquer the world but so does cain to
conquer and so they usually end up
bumping heads in terms of their various
schemes there is a kind of respect among
them it's grudging and the sense where
doom like respects what it is that
king's capable of and kang respects doom
then there's also the the link that
marvel has kind of created or teased but
never actually solidified that kane the
conqueror may very well be descended
from doctor doom we never get a
definitive answer on that we don't know
if that's actually the case but
regardless of the situation doom sees
this as a chance to take out two birds
with one stone and so what you have is a
massive battle that basically takes
place between the three of them to a
degree now when i say to a degree it's
because it's really more king the
conqueror trying to take out doctor doom
and then it's nathaniel trying to reason
with king and the reason why he says
that is because he says look ultimately
the immediate threat here is doctor doom
but you in you know in the in your
future will come back and find me and
when you find me you're going to take me
to the through the time stream and
you're going to try to correct all the
flaws in yourself by correcting those
flaws of me teaching me those lessons
never love different things along those
lines right love is a weakness the the
fact that you fell in love with ravana
rinslayer is what led to you becoming as
weak and incapable as you are if i don't
have any of those weaknesses i will
become ruthless in a way that you never
work i will become every ounce conqueror
but at the end of the day i can just
teach you those things myself i come
from what is in effect your future right
like i know your history i know what
happens to you like i know these
conflicts right i know what happens to
you running all the way up until like
the 31st century so i know how your
battles with the avengers will unfold i
know all that stuff so just let me teach
you those things right let me teach you
how you lost so that you can win and so
as a result of that the bargain is
struck the deal is made kang says okay
they basically end up ejecting uh dr
doom from the ship using using you know
time mechanics and then once doctor
dooms out of the picture the response of
kang is okay let's do this and the
response to nathaniel is no right doom
was 100 right kang is not to be trusted
your time is done and he fires on him he
literally executes his older self right
just kills him right there and then
shoots him to death and it's just this
amazing moment where where king says
king is dead long live king and the
argument that he makes here what he's
basically saying is you are going to
become me there's no way you're not
there's no way you can't right like you
are doing exactly what i would have done
right like you like whether you know it
or not you are walking headlong into
this role you're walking headlong into
becoming king and so that's what's so
funny here because at this point once
kang is dead nathaniel says okay now i
can execute my plan i can don the
moniker of ramatat and i can go back to
ancient egypt and i can save the life of
ravana renislayer i won't use the diode
raid that forces her to bend to my will
instead like i will i will conquer egypt
right i will see my younger self so in
effect it's exactly everything that we
saw happening in the last video that we
covered it's all unfolding the
difference here is that the motivation
of ramat is different but everything
else is the exact same right his younger
self is there so on and so forth and he
tells ravana like okay so like like
basically i'm going to take you to a
place where i'm going to keep you safe
right i'm going to take you to the
citadel it's going to keep you safe
everything's going to be fine but he
still operates its ramen's hut by all
standards of measurement he's still a
villain because it's the role he has to
play in order to save the life of ravana
you see how he's falling down this path
of becoming king right like you see how
like he's just continually becoming this
guy and that's when the fantastic four
show up and they see him as rama tut the
fight unfolds and so he says i did
exactly what kane the conqueror would
have done right what rahmatut did
initially i fled so regardless of the
fact that he's trying to do things
differently in the end he's doing them
the exact same way the timeline unfolds
the exact same way and that's really the
bigger focus here is that time is not
something you can just control and
manipulate however you want to it has a
finite form and function it starts at a
and it ends at z and that there are
things that happen in between where you
can kind of fudge them a little bit but
at the end of the day there are fixed
points in the universe's history that
cannot be changed they cannot be
modified they cannot be adjusted there
are universal constants that have to
exist in the universe king the conqueror
is a universal constant rama tut's
existence is a universal point in the
time stream that cannot be adjusted it
always happens how it is that he wants
it to happen is irrelevant but it always
happens right he basically like no
matter what would take place here no
matter what his thought process would be
no matter what would happen it would be
him traveling back as ramatant and he
would give people science but he would
still be rama tut there's no way to
escape that so what ends up happening is
once he is once he flees and gets away
as best he can he ends up in the
far-flung future in 4000 a.d and the
first person he's greeted by is ravana
rinslayer which begs the question how do
ravana rim slayer survive from the days
of ancient egypt to now with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this to an
end again i don't know about you guys i
love this cane the conqueror story it's
probably it's the the single greatest
kang story that i've ever read in my
life absolutely love it so yeah we're
gonna bring this to an end thank you all
for watching and i will catch you all
later
peace